hey can i just say say something to you
about sal you know because you were
talking about sal
earlier you know he really is a good
hearted guy
but it's one thing i've noticed about
him he
like if you just hang out with him long
enough he'll do something stupid to [ __ ]
it up
it's almost like he's one of those guys
that if you're in a room and there's
silence
he'll feel compelled to say something
and it's always inappropriate
here he is from the wrap-up show and he
says that he knew bobby flay he met
bobby flay up here what happened was
bobby flay was walking around the lobby
next thing i see bobby flay and his wife
are in sal studio
sal is a huge fan like like really a big
fan so i guess he grabbed them
and was showing him around oh yeah and
then he says the wrong thing
yeah now listen to this the day bobby
flay came in
you went out and found him brought him
back and showed him around i'm not even
sure he was looking to see our space
yeah it was a little uncomfortable i
said a few things that i i might have
like what well i ate at his restaurant
and uh he was there with his wife who's
beautiful by the way beautiful and uh i
said look i go
i had one of your your burgers at the
smith haven mall bobby's burgers
and i said how can i put this and i go
well there's a woman here but you can
imagine what i'm talking about in my
mouth
and i realized that i was trying to be
polite but when i walked away i said you
know even putting it that way
it was probably i don't understand what
he meant what do you what does
it mean [ __ ] in my mouth you know it's
like eating [ __ ] you know i go
i put that burger in my mouth and it was
like and i look at her go there's a lady
here but
you can imagine what i'm talking about
being in my mouth and how did he react
uh shocked a little bit and just like
kept moving on and
it was pretty awkward first of all sal
is such a [ __ ] pervert that like
when you talk about food who thinks
about [ __ ] [ __ ] doesn't taste
that great that it would be like oh my
god this hamburger yes this hamburger is
so
good this hamburger is so good it tastes
like [ __ ] i mean like
if your hamburger tastes like [ __ ]
you're probably gonna be out of business
right well the old me would have said it
it's better than [ __ ] in my mouth i
censored myself i'm actually utilizing
my filter listen to me
you're such a [ __ ] nitwit yeah really
yeah you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
doing in life
that is so whacked out he thought he was
doing a good thing
the guy probably looked at you like i
would be like this guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
howard i swear to you i really thought
you know what i mean the old me would
have been like oh i put your burger in
my mouth that was like having a [ __ ] in
there was
fantastic but i saw the lady and i was a
gentleman i go
i i saw his wife who was beautiful and i
i saw her and i go bobby when i bit your
burger it was like and i paused and i
said
it was like well i can't say but it was
like that woman's thing in your mouth
first of all from a common sense point
of view you know [ __ ]
if if a hamburger tasted like [ __ ] they
gotta be out of business well it depends
what time of night it is
jd says jd tells me that that is sal's
go-to analogy whatever he's talking
about how it's great
you know you know what i mean man loves
[ __ ] so no one loves to stick his dick
in [ __ ] okay but what better way to
compliment the chef but even if you were
going to use a crude reference you'd say
your hamburger tastes so good and the
way [ __ ] feels on my [ __ ]
like in other words oh okay not the way
[ __ ] is in your mouth
that's the first thing oh you'd say this
hamburger is better than sex
right right why couldn't he say
something intelligent well
well the same way you you don't
visualize uh
[ __ ] in your mouth i don't visualize
like [ __ ] a hamburger better than sex
would be like
are you implying you're [ __ ] no you
know what i'm trying to say i see it
differently
i know you see things so differently
that you're odd i'm sorry
bobby flay like he's standing there with
his wife he just said hey you make a
great hamburger i'm a huge fan
it's my favorite thing to eat right it's
better than the grape it's
better than anything my father owned the
pizzeria it's better than his pizza you
know it's better right
something but you go it's better than
what a woman has between her legs and
right i don't want to offend but uh
[ __ ] i mean you can't it's insane
after i said it i can't ironic by the
way his wife looked at me
i had the feeling that even though i
didn't say the word [ __ ] she still made
the
face as as if i did what you don't know
when you're talking to somebody what
their sensitivity is
to any kind of crudeness so why would
you use
anything like that like it's the first
time you meet because i figure you're an
adult
and you've been through a lot of things
you're figuring that's what i'm saying
you don't
know there's something mentally wrong
with you that is such an outrageous
thing to say to this guy
i am one of the biggest bobby flay fans
in the world when i got had the
opportunity to meet him i said how can i
express my love of his burger in a way
that
only a man